welcome back to my Harry Potter series
and this time we're talking about Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire the very
first pg-13 Harry Potter as well as the
first Harry Potter to no longer be
scored by John Williams this time
Patrick Doyle took over those reigns
this was directed by Mike Newell and
told the story of the legendary
Triwizard Tournament and the Goblet of
Fire that spits out names of people it
shows him to be a champion and despite
the fact that Harry Potter is not yet of
age to compete in said tournament his
name comes out of the Goblet of Fire and
now he has to step up and try to prove
himself while also solving the mystery
of why he's even being included in this
tournament while also dealing with an
entire school who are looking down on
him for the fact that he even gets to
participate in said tournament because
he's not old enough yet so this was the
first Harry Potter movie to open without
the evil vile der sleaze Harry is now
away from them and is thank God for that
those people are asked ma'am every time
I see them in these movies it's just
like oh stay away from my Harry Potter
he's a good man you stay away from that
boy we'll talk more about horrible vile
characters in my review for the order of
the Phoenix but the Harry Potter series
has some truly awful people inhabiting
it and that family man that family is
just they're the devil but this movie
gets to the action really quickly Harry
Hermione and Ron are whisked away to
watch the World Cup of Quidditch in
which Death Eaters eventually take over
the area destroying everything there are
aspects of this scene that felt very
abrupt and my only way of explaining it
could be that perhaps they weren't quite
sure how dark they could really go yet
and get away with because this is the
first pg-13 Harry Potter and it's easily
the darkest one we've had so far in
regards to more mature content so this
whole sequence where the Death Eaters
are destroying everything and burning
everything it felt very rushed this
movie also introduced the character of
Cedric Diggory played by Robert
Pattinson that's right before he was
Edward he was also in the Harry Potter
series and something I haven't really
talked about yet in these reviews is how
awesome the Postal Service and the Harry
Potter universe is the fact that letters
are delivered by owls our Postal Service
here where I live is atrocious I will
often get other people's mail I will
often have to go to the post office to
retrieve my mail because they simply
didn't deliver it my word how much I
would give to have Hedwig as my Postal
Service how great would that be
so Goblet of Fire absolutely explored
puberty more Harry and Hermione and Ron
are starting to get a little older
little cute looks that other students is
now turning into something a little more
important than that there's a dance in
this film
all of a sudden pressure is mounted on
the students about who they're going to
ask and Goblet of Fire wisely wisely
plays much of this for comedy it is not
taken overly seriously whenever
something more dramatic happens in
regards to the whole boy-girl situation
that goes on throughout this movie it
feels warranted and it feels deserved
but the majority of it is played for
humor and so as an older person I can
watch this and be like man I remember
trying to do that I don't want to
ever even think about doing that again
there's this great scene where Harry's
like I think I'd rather face the dragon
again then ask a girl to this dance and
that's one of the biggest reasons why
the Harry Potter universe and this movie
in particular works so well because they
relate everyday average situations that
we can relate to while somehow throwing
that magical fantasy element into it
Harry would rather face a dragon again
then ask a girl to the dance this movie
also introduced Brendan Gleeson as
Alastor Moody and extremely etc teacher
with a deep knowledge of the dark arts
he used to train people in defense
against the dark arts and so he wants to
teach these kids how to defend
themselves from things that he's pretty
sure are coming and there's some really
entertaining sequences as well as
actually some very powerful sequences in
which he attempts to explain to these
kids some of the forbidden curses so
even though Harry is experiencing some
blossoming feelings of youth for some
other students that he's not sure of and
he's never felt before in a hilarious
scene he is absolutely not very amused
by Hagrid's newfound love I thought
perhaps you had forgotten me
forget you of them what is it you wanted
to show me but as I'm sure a lot of you
know if he ever grew up with somebody
we're friends with said person and then
you start going through puberty
that's when complications arise and in
this film Harry and Ron get into an
argument over a misunderstanding and so
it also explores that aspect of
friendship as well very well in fact but
that also leads me to one thing that
confused me about this movie and I feel
that it was perhaps a mistake of
direction something wasn't communicated
properly to Rupert Grint as Ron Weasley
in the scene where Harry in the
Triwizard Tournament is facing off
against the dragon Ron is cheering for
Harry and it was just so strange because
he's very pissed at Harry at this time I
don't think that communication was made
to Rupert Grint that no you're supposed
to still kind of be upset with Harry
there's never a cutaway to Ron more
upset when Harry defeats the dragon he's
just perfectly fine with it all and it
seems kind of contrary to what ron was
feeling at the time that being said
though the start of this triwizard
tournament and watching Harry face off
against that dragon was so much fun you
feel for this kid so much he is very
much so the normal average kid that we
can all relate to he's the Peter Parker
you know he's the guy that has the
everyday problems but is also facing
these otherworldly situations and it is
an absolute blast to watch eventually
just like in real life when friends are
arguing they eventually make up and Ron
and Harry make up in this movie which
leads to some really truly hilarious
scenes when Ron gets the outfit that his
parents want him to wear to the dance
and oh my god it's just these characters
you know I mean it's so easy for this to
become melodramatic it's so easy for
this to become a soap opera and for you
to just be like oh look they're all in
love now but it's not like that because
they play it with such maturity as I
said a lot of it is played for humor
it's it's not played overly serious and
so you can relate to it more because you
understand
in retrospect how some of those
situations you go through and youth are
very funny the whole dance sequence is
done really well you get the first time
where Harry actually looks at Hermione
and perhaps sees a woman and it's
captured beautifully it's not captured
as oh my God look how attracted I am to
this person it's oh my God look how
beautiful you are it's just done
perfectly they really had to be careful
with that scene but they
absurd that tone really well and that
whole dance sequence is very funny
I love how Neville is getting really
into the dancing like he's taking it
super seriously the next challenge
involves having to stay underwater for
an hour
Harry ingest this plant that allows him
to grow gills and we get this really
terrific scene where he rescues not just
his friend but the other person's friend
as well Harry's the best of the best
he's a true hero I love this character
it's a great example for kids and that's
another thing about this movie that I
really appreciate there's a line towards
the end where Dumbledore says it's time
for you to choose between what is right
and what is easy and this is a fantastic
message because that is what we all face
in everyday life and it's really good
for kids to learn this in a way that
they can enjoy and entertain but also it
teaches them an important message this
movie does struggle though with a lot of
exposition storytelling there's a lot of
dreams
a lot of visions you can tell they're
trying to cram a big book into one movie
in fact at one point they were actually
thinking of splitting it into two films
but gratefully they didn't do that so
the final challenge in the Triwizard
Tournament is the maze from the shining
let's open it one isn't in they're
hiding somewhere because that would
really suck there is one thing I want to
say about this though the entire
sequence is really tense I really really
love it
but imagine that you were actually the
audience watching this tournament once
everyone goes in the trees encapsulate
them and I guess the crowd just kind of
sits there and waits no one would
actually go to that imagine going to the
Super Bowl and then like this big
drapery just covers the entire field and
you just sit there hoping that the
football game is a lot of fun but you
can't see it that being said that what
we get to see as audience members not
the people there for the tournament but
us it's awesome this is extremely
important for Harry Voldemort appears
Voldemort is finally there in his form
played by ray Fiennes brilliantly we
learn more about Harry's parents and we
get our first glimpse of epic showdowns
that are to come when Harry faces off
very briefly against Voldemort and
Cedric Diggory does die but what was so
powerful about this moment was when
Harry's parents read his side's trying
to help him defeat Voldemort trying to
helped him it was just like oh my gosh
this is so great
it reminded me of when Gohan and cell
are doing a Kamehameha wave against each
other and Goku is right there by Gohan
trying to inspire him up I would be the
only person to see a comparison of
Dragon Ball Z and Harry Potter wouldn't
I this whole thing ends and Daniel
Radcliffe is really magnificent towards
the finale this movie he gives a really
good performance and I felt so much for
him in this film he really really sold
all of that important needed emotion
Dumbledore's eulogy for Cedric Diggory
was very touching everything about the
way this movie ends is a very good hint
at what's to come some truly emotional
shits gonna go down and they pulled it
off again
another really good Harry Potter movie
I'm gonna give Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire and a - guys thank you so
much for continuing to go on this
journey with me as I watch all the Harry
Potter films leading up to fantastic
beasts and where to find them
coming up very soon Harry Potter and the
order of the Phoenix you guys are the
best thank you so much as always for
watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes